yes
hello sorry just a second
so i guess everyone can see me
so uh this is me shubham footy uh
student of genetic engineering and
biotechnology at university of turkey
so i have currently been in a research
fellowship program in comics logic
bioinformatics
dr harpit madam uh has been my
supervisor
so today i am going to discuss my
journey and how
mentors and this internship helped me to
gain knowledge and idea about developing
a project and what i did
so what did i do actually well
first of all all courses and projects
yeah
i or you who are going to do this
research fellowship will gain access to
after enrolling
well they will guide you and they have
they will be super helpful
and they will be fun i remember for the
first time i didn't feel bored when i
studied and went through these courses
all day then the knowledge you gained
from these courses and projects will
help you
to do works for the research project
later on
and also these projects will uh guide
you in various courses as
uh dr ella already said like in
transcriptomics or genomics and
in any and you can also do the projects
you will feel interested
into also apart from using
bioinformatics tools i was
also exposed to the world of programming
of data science and bioinformatics
it was a nice experience when you
realize you can visualize your data set
with r
and you can do lots of analysis one
thing that is
not mentioned anywhere today that is you
will know some cool people and make
friends around when you do this project
for example i did make some good friends
uh where
undergraduate as me i came to know
people who are senior researchers or
pursuing phd
it is very helpful when you get this
exposure
i think i talk enough about what why i
love it here
i'll give you a short summary of my work
so this is the research question i
choose
so this is the one how the third dose of
malaria says
s1 vaccine is associated with control
information and in his protection
so before going further uh i want to
tell you how i came to this research
question
well when i choose a research program
first it was you know it was vast and
not
specific i remember my mentors helped me
to be
specific and they guided me like you
have to choose a good data set
they have to they have to be properly
utilized and also the problem
that has to be unique and novel the
first time i choose a problem that was a
novel and the data set was so
small and you know they
all the processes okay so
i wanted to mention that also four or
five months ago i didn't know much about
bioinformatics analysis
or how to deal with dataset or how to
interpret result or how to do multiple
type of comics
analysis so here in the internship
you'll learn all of those
from the courses and projects and not to
mention the
mentors will guide you whenever you are
stuck or
you do a mistake so i want to
tell you why i choose malaria because i
guess
anita just before me she explained
everything why it is
still a crucial problem and it is taking
lots of lives
those of us who live in asia or in
europe
we do not understand that but you know
in africa it is affecting very badly
so i will now show you some of the
analysis that we
did and i will not go into the technical
details at this
in this slide you can find out that uh
after differential gene
expression analysis uh in either we
found 219 genes are significantly
expressed
while we compared between
pre-vaccination estate and the day of
challenge day of challenge is
uh was three weeks after the vaccination
where you know controlled human malaria
infection was applied
also you can see the threshold for uh
our
result also here you can see
it is a volcano plot for all the genes
we use psec to
uh achieve this and this is the heat map
i
also want to mention that you can all do
it in the
performance that the filler showed you
before on and also you can do it by
yourself in the
r if you go through the courses also
this pca plot
here for example let us see why this is
important
so you can see these samples they are
there the below one the day 40 samples
they are you know different from other
groups they are not together
also there one and there three are these
two uh
i guess you can see sorry here yeah day
one and day three samples they are
together
from other groups and you know the day
of challenge here
they are here so we can
interpret many things for example
in our study we found out that cytokine
related genes were
significantly expressed so
uh conclusion over expression of
cytokines is associated with
you know uh driving forces of death in
malaysia related disease
so here we try to find out uh
how those genes which are significantly
expressed
uh affect the pathways and uh we did
enrich
as you can see and in the platform we
did the human gaze
analysis here we we can see the
significant
genes uh in our analysis they are
involved in
cytokine related pathway so we came to
this conclusion
how malaria vaccination helps to down
regulated
those genes the cytokine ones which
would
which would otherwise you know increase
the severity of malaria
and increase the chance of death so we
visualized our data set and we
analyzed it and uh and that is all
so i i i haven't gone into the details
because there is short time and
i think it would be best if i give you
an
idea what they did so that will be
all uh and i want to thank find biotech
for giving me this
chance to present and do this analysis
and thank you everyone
thank you